les québécois taxe un médecin
spécialiste en tout temps deux visions
s'affrontent la proche du ministre
barrette et celle des médecins
spécialistes
d'après ce qu'on trompe rangs de
l'entente proposée par le gouvernement
ce sont les médecins spécialistes qui
ont en grande partie gain de cause
les médecins spécialistes étaient
furieux contre la loi 130 qui donnait
beaucoup de pouvoir au ministre de la
santé mary c'est my way en ont mais
comme on dit en bon français ce qu'elle
reproche entre autres les médecins à la
loi 130 c'est que le ministre barrette
peut dresser une liste de médecins de
garde qui ont l'obligation de répondre
aux appels des hôpitaux qui ont besoin
d'eux or avec l'entente le ministre
semble clairement perdre ce pouvoir ce
sont plutôt les médecins qui avec leur
propre argent vont déterminer des
incitatifs adéquat pour s'assurer que
les spécialistes vont aller aux endroits
où on a besoin d'eux par contre si ça ne
fonctionne pas si ali services qui ne
sont pas rendus à la population
les médecins fautif pourrait recevoir
une pénalité allant jusqu'à 3000 $ et on
pourrait imposer des amendes allant
jusqu'à 200 mille dollars à leur
association